il traite 350 affaires par an moi j'ai
souvenir d'un petit gamin de 4 4 5 ans
qui présentait nombreuses traces de
violence par son père en fait qu'il
avait battu à l'extrême quoi je pense
que là là on est on n'a pas été loin de
l'homicide
[Musique]
pendant que je dormais tout le temps il
voulait que je dormais avec lui
entendre et celui qui dit que ça prend
pas au ventre
moi personnellement j'y crois pas
sinon qu'est-ce qui va se passer
monsieur si vous ne respectez pas votre
contrôle judiciaire qu'est-ce qui va se
passer
vous savez pas une révocation de votre
contrôle judiciaire et un placement des
tensions provisoires ça veut dire
l'incarcération vous voulez aller en
prison monsieur
palais de justice de Béthune dans l'un
des 156 tribunaux pour enfants
ils sont 440 juges des enfants sur le
territoire français waouh donc là vous
pouvez dire une Marianne que vous
attendez depuis quatre ans quatre ans
ici ils sont 6 pour traiter 5000
affaires par an au pénal et au civil
[Musique]
alors on se voit aujourd'hui je vous
explique non pas pour vous juger on vous
reproche des faits que je vais vous
rappeler je vais vous poser des
questions sur ces faits vous répondez
aux questions votre maman pendant tout
ce temps ne dit rien vous aurez votre
temps pour vous exprimer je vous
demanderai dans un second temps comment
ça se passe avec
et puis je verrai si je le mets en
examen en fonction de ce qui m'explique
par rapport au fait qu'il se reprochait
et j'expliquerai ce que veut dire une
mise en examen en fonction de ce que
j'ai décidé de réparation ce matin parce
qu'elle a convoqué un adolescent de 16
ans récidiviste qu'il suit depuis deux
ans
alors on vous reproche d'avoir à
Noyelles-Godault le 26 mars 2009
frauduleusement soustrait un baladeur
DJX et un cutter au préju du magasin en
show est-ce que vous comprenez ce que je
viens de vous indiquer
est-ce que vous reconnaissez ces faits
vivre à la limite vous m'auriez dit mon
patron c'était le responsable du magasin
et pour me venger je lui ai fait ça mais
là ça n'avait aucun lien et de ce que
vous avez dit à la police en fait vous
avez volé dans un premier temps le
cutter et le cutter il vous a servi à
enlever l'emballage du baladeur
vous allez me dire j'ai oublié de
remettre le cutter dans le dans le rayon
enfin
vous envisagez en faire quoi de se
balader
c'est pour vous
vous en pensez quoi de ce que vous avez
fait
pour quelle raison de voir comment
commencer
ça vaut quoi d'après vous ce que vous
avez fait
ça vous la prison ou pas
un vol avec des gradations ça peut
valoir 50 ans
c'est cher payé non
on va lui faire faire un travail
peut-être écrit sur la loi on va
peut-être lui faire un petit travail au
profit de la collectivité il faut
essayer les restos du cœur des fois
c'est ramasser des feuilles
[Musique]
je préfère qu'il fait ça qui comprennent
que tes vents présents
c'est pas à la place d'aller en prison
on jugera un moment donné mais moi je
veux savoir je veux être sûr qu'il est
venu qu'il est réellement compris que
c'était pas à refaire et qu'il a compris
la gravité donc la mesure de réparation
elle va me servir à mesurer ça il y a de
faire réfléchir
donc d'accord
à l'éducateur quand il sera convoqué
au travail
la mesure de réparation elle se passe
bien moi j'entends pas parler de vous
bah je serai assez tenté de réorienter
ce dossier dans mon cabinet c'est à dire
de le juger dans mon bureau si je vous
juge dans mon bureau ça veut dire que je
m'interdis de vous envoyer en prison
mais par contre si vous continuez à
faire parler de vous et que vous n'avez
visiblement pas compris bah je renverrai
ce dossier au tribunal pour enfants je
joue jugerai avec deux autres collègues
et en présence du procureur de la
République et là vous encourez la prison
donc c'est à vous de mettre à profit ce
temps entre la mise en examen et le
jugement on s'est bien compris au revoir
madame
au revoir
on va mettre
j'ai choisi les enfants parce que je
pense que c'est l'une des fonctions par
excellence où on peut être au service
des gens au service du public on peut
contribuer à ce que la justice soit
perçue comme humaine et c'est vrai qu'on
travaille parfois au cœur de la misère
humaine
tout en
étant magistrat en apportant sa
connaissance mais en rendant justice
parce que le boulot de juge des enfants
c'est à la fois de protéger des mineurs
en danger c'est aussi parfois de punir
des mineurs délinquants et on a vraiment
le sentiment d'être
utile
détecter les problèmes le plus tôt
possible protégez trouver des solutions
éducatives ou condamnées le juge des
enfants et la pièce maîtresse de la
justice des mineurs un système
précurseur néolandin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en 45 se retrouve au
ministère de la justice des hommes et
des femmes qui ont eu à subir
plus que la privation de liberté qui ont
eu à subir l'horreur
du totalitarisme du nazisme ces gens-là
reviennent des camps de la mort et
autour autour de du garde des Sceaux de
l'époque de magistrats issus de la
résistance
de gens qui étaient tantôt des chrétiens
tantôt des communistes et rédiger
l'ordonnance
du 2 février 1945 signé par le général
de Gaulle
ancien éducateur ancien directeur de
prison pour mineur Jean-Louis Daumas est
aujourd'hui directeur de l'École
nationale de la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse il connaît bien la
philosophie de ce texte fondateur
[Musique]
dit pour l'essentiel que lorsqu'un jeune
commet une infraction pénale ce qui doit
retenir l'attention de la société et
donc du juge ça n'est pas tant le fait
qu'il peut y avoir un vélo qui a été
volé qui a été chapardé mais ce qui doit
retenir l'attention du juge c'est bien
la personnalité et l'histoire du jeûne
qui est chapardé le vélo on va donc
s'attacher à la personnalité à
l'histoire du voleur de vélo plutôt
qu'au dommage causés par l'infraction
elle-même donner la primauté à
l'éducatif sur le répressif pour éviter
l'enfermement la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse peut placer les mineurs
dans des familles d'accueil des foyers
ou des centres éducatifs toujours sous
le contrôle d'éducateur spécialisé
un suivi de longue haleine qui sortent
souvent à des réalités familiales et
sociales complexes je vais commencer
par aujourd'hui la juge mère reçoit en
audience Bernard 17 ans et demi
multiré ses divistes il ne suit pas les
conditions de son contrôle judiciaire
c'est à la demande de Morad son
éducateur que Bernard a été convoqué
avec ses parents divorcés
tu es d'accord moi
les deux
c'est toujours ce problème des trous
noirs
[Musique]
Bernard avait l'obligation de suivre des
soins médicaux liés à son addiction
cannabis et d'intégrer un stage de
formation professionnelle
alors sur votre situation actuelle on a
quand même mis en place un certain
nombre de mesures éducatives vous avez
été confié à la communauté Albert
Châtelet ensuite il y a eu un placement
en CER qui a été ordonnée depuis le
retour chez votre maman comment ça se
passe
ça se passe bien
donc je vais vous laisser la parole
monsieur rabat déjà sur ce point là
comment les choses se mettent en place
avec justement
de consommation niveau cannabis et
alcool on a essayé de travailler avec
des missions impossibles on a donc ton
télé placement
il y a eu diverses projets il y a eu des
CFA mis en place et à chaque fois donc
au bout de deux à trois mois tous ces
fonds il est gentil bon ça a un garçon
très gentil moi j'ai jamais eu de
problème avec ce jeune
sauf qui je répondais dire qu'il dit
tout le temps oui et au final il fait
jamais rien donc on a vraiment du mal
nous à comprendre un peu dans quel champ
de compétences est-ce qu'on est dans un
champ de compétence
éducatif ou si quoi en fait
parce que sinon qu'est-ce qui va se
passer monsieur
contrôle judiciaire qu'est-ce qui va se
passer
vous savez pas je vous l'avais expliqué
quand même monsieur
une révocation de votre contrôle
judiciaire et un placement des tensions
provisoires ça veut dire une
incarcération vous voulez aller en
prison monsieur
Rabat dans son écrit que vous n'êtes pas
motivé pour le moment vous n'êtes pas en
demande d'une formation et vous attendez
vos 18 ans pour travailler c'est ça
mais comment vous pouvez penser encore
une fois à 18 ans vous présenter devant
un employeur sans aucun CV sans aucune
formation parce que vous pensez que vous
allez être embauché
[Musique]
alors en répression je vais prononcer
une mesure d'activité de jour pour une
durée de 6 mois la maman est déclarée
civilement responsable donc cette mesure
on reste dans l'éducatif on reste dans
l'accompagnement avant de la d'en
prendre toutes les tous les bienfaits et
de vous mobiliser en ce sens est-ce que
c'est compris monsieur alors l'autre
jour s'est terminé
[Applaudissements]
enfin
ce juste est un c'est un juge qui a
énormément de pouvoir
il instruit une affaire il l'a juge il
se prononce aussi ville au pénal depuis
2000 depuis 2005 il est aussi celui qui
peut statuer sur l'application des
peines mais c'est d'abord celui qui va
essayer de concilier de concilier
l'intérêt de l'enfant avec notre intérêt
à nous tous qui sommes la société civile
et ça effectivement ça le singularise
par rapport à d'autres juges
depuis quelques années la délinquance
des mineurs est devenue un enjeu
politique et la notion de tolérance zéro
est apparue
[Musique]
avec la primauté de l'éducatif sur le
répressif l'esprit de 1945 est appliqué
mais la création en 1998 des centres
éducatif renforcés et surtout en 2002
avec la loi Perben 1 la création des
centres éducatifs fermés et des
établissements pénitentiaires pour
mineurs marque un premier durcissement
en 2007 la première prison pour mineur
ouvre ses portes
[Musique]
en décembre 2008 la Commission Varina
remet un rapport à la garde des sourds
Rachida Dati 70 propositions pour
réformer en profondeur le code pénal des
mineurs dont l'emblématique enfermement
dès l'âge de 12 ans pour certains une
nécessité pour lutter contre la hausse
continue de la délinquance juvénile et
pour d'autres la primauté donnée au tour
et précis et l'abandon de l'esprit de
1945 c'est un texte qui a besoin tout
simplement d'être remis en cohérence
mais sans en changer l'esprit je crois
que c'est très important de ne pas en
changer l'esprit ce qui ne veut pas dire
pour autant que tous les mineurs doivent
être l'été exactement de la même façon
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné un
mineur qui est passé 10 fois 15 fois 20
fois et je pourrais continuer devant une
juridiction pour enfants et bien
peut-être il va falloir prendre une
solution plus répressive mais sans pour
autant oublier qu'il doit y avoir
d'éducation on assiste en réalité à une
américanisation du système dans l'aspect
progressivité des mesures qui tient
compte uniquement des contactez pas de
la personnalité attendre récidive sur
une personne qui a telle casier sur tel
type de mesure et tel type de grand
homme de peine ça vaudra tant puis voilà
c'est déjà largement ce qui se passe sur
les majeurs et d'une manière assez
terrifiante quand même quand on met les
pieds dans des dans des audiences
correctionnelles chez les majeurs je
tiens dans les grandes agglomérations de
voir les gens juger en 7 ou 8 minutes
chrono on en est là donc malheureusement
le drame et que on veut faire la même
chose avec les mineurs
en mars 2009 le projet de loi ne reprend
pas dans son intégralité les
propositions de la Commission Varina
si l'âge minimal d'enfermement reste à
13 ans s'il n'est plus question d'un
tribunal correctionnel pour mineur le
parquet peut faire juger un jeune en
urgence en se passant de la phase de
l'instruction le juge des enfants semble
voir sa mission rogner au profit du
parquet
ça Clive les politiques qui nous
gouvernent on voit bien qu'il se sépare
là-dessus ça n'est pas parce qu'on fait
ce travail
sur la responsabilité individuelle et
sur le sens de l'existence et des actes
qu'il faut évidemment se dispenser de se
soucier en même temps de l'insertion
sociale de ces jeunes parce que ces
jeunes immensément pratiquement tous ils
sortent quand même des milieux les plus
Pau paupérisés les plus modestes les
plus abîmés par les conditions de
l'existence
direction l'un des 38 CEF centre
éducatif fermé
[Musique]
un programme qui concerne 320 mineurs en
France
[Musique]
donc on va au centre éducatif fermé de
Liévin et les spécialiser sur une
tranche d'âge 13 16 ans puisque la
majorité la responsabilité pénale est
engagée à partir de 13 ans et qu'on a
plutôt comme point d'appui la scolarité
parce que c'est déjà une qui ont
régulièrement été en échec scolaire et
puis il y a d'autres CEF qui sont plus
spécialisés sur les 16 18 avec le côté
apprentissage recherche en tout cas
découverte à un certain nombre de
métiers voilà le centre éducatif fermé
donc on va se garer et voyez il y a pas
de concertina il y a pas de mirador on
est on est sur une fermeture juridique
on n'est pas sur une fermeture de type
contention carcéral
ici pas de cellules pas de mirador mais
des règles de vie strictes et des
sorties sous conditions et sur avis du
juge au centre 16 éducateurs pour 10
enfants tous placés pour une durée de 6
mois renouvelable
violence aggravée vol séquestration
trafic et consommation de drogues tout
sont des parcours judiciaire lourd
[Musique]
on réapprend à vivre à horaire fixe
et on s'impose une hygiène de vie pour
ses enfants la vie en collectivité c'est
un peu la dernière chance avant la case
prison moi je promets je prends pas de
lancement à la plage
il y a des appels au secours dans
l'entrée à la délinquance et les membres
qui vont pas bien qui ont rien fait à
l'école qui sont passés à côté de plein
de en lançants que personne n'a entendu
il va considérer qu'on se metteur en
danger c'est la seule manière pour lui
de d'essayer de vérifier si il a appris
et s'il a une valeur pour la société la
France n'est pas assez riche d'enfants
pour négliger tout ce qui peut en faire
des êtres sains et bien voilà ça fait
partie du coup qu'on a à supporter mais
la prison est à coup aussi avec l'espoir
que bien sûr ce soit un coup d'arrêt
mais ça marche pas à tous les coups le
CEF participe aussi de cette d'une des
réponses en espérant que ça marche et ça
marche pas toujours mais ça marche
globalement plutôt mieux vraiment le
deal qui leur est donné c'est de dire si
tu es en capacité de montrer après
l'acte que tu as commis qui est quand
même un acte grave en général pour
arriver dans un centre éducatif fermé si
tu es capable de montrer que tu te
tu comprends la portée de l'acte que tu
as commis et bien il y a des chances
pour que tu ne passes pas forcément par
la case prison alors que le fait qui
était reproché le justifierait
certains enfants placés au CES
autorisation de suivre des cours à
l'extérieur mais pour les plus des
scolarisés c'est l'école au centre avec
un professeur détaché par l'Éducation
nationale
ok donc
même si tu es un peu fatigué on va
devoir faire l'évaluation finale dans
cette classe des enfants de 13 à 16 ans
qui ont le niveau scolaire du CM2 écrit
là
on compte combien il y a de chiffres
derrière la virgule 2 donc je vais
compter 2
ça fait combien Emmanuel à 13 ans
qu'est-ce qu'on propose ici comme
solution
si je veux réussir dans la vie faut que
je commence à me mettre de maintenant
parce que
on cherche à voir un peu aussi comment
il fonctionne et ce qui marche avec eux
parce que je veux dire ce que vous
mettez en place avec l'arbre marchera
peut-être pas forcément avec l'autre
ou un verbe d'action
qui s'investissent dans une formation en
sortant d'ici quoi
et apprentissage comme pour Pascal qui
est formé au métier de jardinier
je veux que tu mettes tes lunettes c'est
tout
je t'ai pas demandé d'aimer je t'ai
demandé de les mettre
parce que
moi plus je peux éliminer les risques
oui je suis content allez
Pascal est au centre depuis 7 mois
[Musique]
je travaille j'aime bien travailler tout
ça alors ça me plaît travailler
débroussailler au moins je suis pas en
prison
non je vais aller directement à présent
mais mon éducateur mieux ouvert et
préférée et à Dieu
en Suède ça va je suis content là
c'est un peu grave
briser le silence libérez la parole pour
les éducateurs c'est la priorité
[Musique]
s
de prison pour jarodite la Cour a
condamné en soit à 15 ans de prison
alors ça valait le coup pour 1500 euros
à base ils étaient partis pour faire
1500 euros déjà pour pour un acte
illégal déjà tu vois on paye pour
commettre des délits et au final ils
prennent en plus 15 ans tu vois et c'est
pas cher payé et je te dis pas encore
subir
La Voix du Nord première chose l'effet
divers quoi ce n'est pas sûr
par rapport à tout ça quoi savoir
dans quelle condition parfois ils
comprennent pas les agissements ou
parfois cautionnes quoi quand il y a des
actes de violence et pour eux c'est
c'est reconnaissent un peu par rapport à
leur histoire il faut un petit parallèle
par rapport à ça et puis bon on fait un
petit débrief par rapport à ça les
affaires comme ça c'est bien de savoir
les risques ce qui se passe en fait
dehors mais reste comprend mais c'est
pas une blanche et ça maintenant tu as
le plancher pour un majeur c'est 3 ans
je crois 2 ans
comprendre plus rapidement simplifier
parce que quand on prend le DALO
en plus comme demain
il est au centre depuis 6 mois
il connaît tout du parcours de l'enfant
délinquants et a même fait 15 jours de
prison
avant d'être resté j'étais dans un autre
dans un autre structure je restais trois
trois quatre mois c'est la galère une
fois que tu es dedans on dirait tu vas
jamais sortir
en fait des mois sur un témoin suivi par
les édules et c'était où tu vois il y a
des éducs en fait ça le truc tu montes
en haut à l'étage
tu te laves il y a des éducs pas loin tu
manges il y a des éducs tu sors dehors
il y a des éducs tu joues au foot des
fois il y a des études
franchement les journaux on dirait ils
se répètent tu fais tous les jours les
mêmes choses et que le matin école
l'après-midi les activités que le matin
l'après-midi les activités
chez toi tu vas voir là tu vas faire un
tour là tu vas faire du casse la voilà
et si tu fais rien
[Musique]
demain Frédéric un rendez-vous avec son
juge il est un peu nerveux tout est
possible il peut rentrer chez lui rester
au centre 6 mois de plus ou être renvoyé
en détention
demain tu seras fixé sur ton agence
tu rentreras ici puis tu auras le temps
de prendre tes habits on va commencer
rapide
elle aurait tout fait tomber et puis
voilà quoi et par contre même si tu sors
tu repars en famille plus difficile ça
va être maintenant
tu peux quand même
dit Monsieur bah je sais pas quelqu'un
va te proposer de faire une connerie moi
aussi tu veux te porter tu en connerie
on va te tempérer toi dehors il y a que
toi qui prendrait décision moi savoir si
tu es prêt maintenant c'est l'heure si
tu es prêt à les prendre
on sait que tu es grand c'est ça on sait
que tu es grand mais parfois
l'importation ben moi je voulais te dire
après midi de détente
départ à la plage pour tout le monde
[Musique]
mais rien n'est jamais simple
Alex excité a ouvert la porte et est
sorti de la voiture
allez c'est un jour comme les autres
la place elle est là
sécurité
là-bas dans le véhicule soit moi je
reste au stop avec toi toute
l'après-midi et sortir quoi pendant
trois semaines pour toi d'accord
[Musique]
direction Berck plage
non on va sortir
les règles tu les connais
courtois on va pas déranger les gens
tout ce qu'ils sont en famille ou quoi
que ce soit et puis bon essaye de se
tenir convenablement on est sorti une
sortie de groupe on essaie de rester en
groupe pourquoi on est sur la plage
au niveau du véhicule moi c'est Prévot
le fait de l'autre côté comme d'habitude
donc voilà après la sortie dépend de
votre comportement ça se passe bien bon
passera une bonne après-midi si bah vous
déranger à la règle on va écourter la
sortie
c'est clair
voilà
[Musique]
il y a pas de prise de risque pour vous
les emmener dans des lieux comme ça
aussi dégagés
en côtoyant d'autres personnes
la fugue aussi la tentation d'être à
l'extérieur et de pouvoir rejoindre un
lieu leurs parents ou échapper du CES
mais bon
la prise de risque elle est là aussi
même à l'interne puisque les fugues
existent aussi au niveau du CEF
c'est pas toujours facile pour eux de la
tentation de pouvoir partir surtout en
début de placement en fin de placement
on en a moins mais en début de placement
c'est plus difficile
donc là il y en a trois
globalement à la plage surtout que bon
bah voilà j'ai constaté qu'il y avait
des gamins qui habitaient pourtant près
de la côte par exemple et qui n'avait
jamais mis les pieds sur une plage
et même à la plage ce ne sont pas des
vacances pour Frédéric le spécialiste
des faits divers qui a rendez-vous
demain avec son juge
après il y en a qui sont respectés par
la force tu sais il y en a qui vont
agresser les gens ils vont avoir une
statut de caïd ça dure qu'un moment
parce qu'un jour ou l'autre cette
personne va être déçu il y a quelqu'un
d'autre qui prendra sa place qu'il
foutra et qui prendra possession tu vois
donc ça sert à rien l'image l'image ça
en fait la grande question c'est aussi
ce différencier c'est en fait qu'on vit
dans les quartiers quand vous venez dans
votre groupe machin etc de vouloir
ressembler aux copains c'est bien un
moment ça va mais problème c'est que
c'est tu maintiens dans ce truc là de
vouloir ressembler aux autres dans la
même image être tous un peu pareil ça
marche pas comme ça
j'en connais
[Musique]
8 heures du matin ou 9h aller commence à
zoner tout ça moi je vais être posé avec
ma meuf alors tu as le droit d'être
différent
[Applaudissements]
une confiance qui s'installe ou le jeune
sang qu'en fait l'adulte j'aimerais dire
c'est que paradoxalement logiquement
prend un peu de distance j'aimerais dire
que
grandir
c'est un centre qui fait grandir c'est
un peu l'école de la vie pour eux
[Applaudissements]
sur les 350 000 mineurs prise en charge
chaque année par la justice plus de 70
000 leçons au titre de l'enfance en
danger
abandon mais aussi coup et viol des
violences qui aboutissent dans les
Brigades des mineurs
[Musique]
je vais donc vous notifier une mesure de
garde à vue
les motifs de votre garde à vue d'accord
c'est ce sur quoi portent l'enquête
c'est viol sur mineur de 15 ans de dire
moins de 15 ans la personne ayant
autorité c'est vous et agression
sexuelle sur mineur de 15 ans par
personne ayant autorité d'accord c'est
ce pourquoi vous êtes ici aujourd'hui
placé en garde à vue d'accord
direction la cellule de garde à vue pour
cet homme suspecté d'avoir abusé de la
petite fille de sa compagne des faits
qu'il ne reconnaît pas alors
je suis sûr que je n'ai pas fait
je sais pas
quand même des choses bizarres
[Musique]
des choses
aussi graves
les choses aussi précises
et on va en reparler tout à l'heure
bien sûr que je veux le savoir
quand même beaucoup ça fait partie du
travail psychologique bien sûr bien sûr
[Musique]
par les parents voilà à Lille ils sont 8
à la brigade des mineurs à travailler
sous la houlette du capitaine flamand
nouveau mari de la grand-mère
tous volontaires comme Joël ancien
gardien de la paix
[Musique]
quotidiennement à des histoires de
famille disloquées
[Musique]
ils traitent 350 affaires par an
moi j'ai souvenir d'un petit gamin de
quatre quatre cinq ans que la mer nous a
amené
et qui présentait de nombreuses traces
de violence
qu'on a d'ailleurs qualifié d'actes de
torture et barbarie un gamin
complètement cassé quoi je veux dire
par son père en fait qu'il avait battu à
l'extrême quoi je pense que là là on est
on n'a pas été loin de l'homicide
et ça ça c'est vrai que ça m'est resté
c'est resté particulièrement ancré dans
ma mémoire et la chose qui m'a encore
plus marquée c'est que cet enfant
n'avait aucune larme c'est-à-dire qu'il
ne pleurait pas de la vie des médecins
légistes ils devaient souffrir il devait
souffrir énormément et pourtant cet
enfant ne pleurait pas il avait je crois
qu'il n'avait plus de larmes
à faire couler
[Musique]
Valérie le petit dernier de la brigade
est arrivé il y a deux mois aujourd'hui
il doit auditionner un jeune adulte de
18 ans qui a décidé de dénoncer les
violences que son beau-père lui aurait
fait subir pendant des années
[Musique]
le jeune homme est venu accompagné de sa
mère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez 18 ans
sexuelles sur vous par exemple
d'accord donc c'est un peu pour ça que
je vous ai demandé de te dire c'est
pour recueillir un maximum d'éléments
pourquoi nous on puisse faire cesser ça
forcément parce que c'est pas normal
d'accord on n'a pas on n'a pas à faire
ce genre de choses
[Applaudissements]
quand je dormais il me tripotait pendant
que je dormais tout le temps il voulait
que je dormais avec lui
donc ça c'était sur les déclarations de
votre maman
à côté de moi non bah dans le lit mes
parents si vous voulez pas que j'ai un
livre et que je dorme avec lui et ma
mère dans le lit
par contre c'est vrai que c'est pas
relativement
bizarre qu'il vous oblige à dormir dans
le dans le mamie on est bien quand c'est
le même lit c'est pas la même chambre
c'est le même
côté lui parce que ma mère elle m'a
avant
j'avais pas ce qui s'était passé
[Musique]
dans ce genre de procédure
on attaque les affaires de caractère
sexuel il faut mettre en confiance
l'enfant c'est pas évident de mettre en
confiance l'enfant
il faut vraiment qu'on les qu'on les
reçoivent comme des victimes ensuite si
des doutes persistent on essaie
d'obtenir la vérité mais dans tous les
cas au départ il faut vraiment que l'on
reçoivent comme une victime mais
et qu'on reçoit un maximum d'éléments
pour pouvoir justement
identifier et faire ressortir les faire
ressortir la faire
si c'est dur parce que entendre
certaines choses d'un enfant c'est pas
toujours facile à entendre et puis
derrière ce policier il y a forcément
quelqu'un qui est peut-être papa qui est
peut-être qui marie qui
homme tout simplement un cul humain tout
simplement et forcément oui ça ouais ça
prend au ventre celui qui dit que ça
prend pas au ventre moi personnellement
j'y crois pas ou alors il a une grande
expérience en matière il faut qu'il
m'explique comment il fait
vous avez des frères et soeurs
est-ce que son victime d'agissement
il va avoir 12 ans l'année prochaine moi
j'ai envie
j'ai autre chose
après avoir fait cette déclaration
un peu
plus tôt
une psychologue ici
[Musique]
c'est juste qu'on puisse nous avoir
une expertise ce que vous ressentez et
répond à certaines questions qu'on peut
se poser
si vous avez des questions faut pas
hésiter dans tous les cas je vais vous
laisser ma carte là vous votre maman
seule chose que je vous demanderai c'est
évidemment c'est de la mettre en lieu
sûr pour pas qu'il ait accès et pour pas
que ça puisse mettre la puce à l'oreille
pour pas qu'il puisse se dire
éventuellement essayer ils m'ont dénoncé
et forcément avoir des représailles le
but étant que nous on arrive d'abord et
qu'on a un maximum d'effets de surprise
d'accord pour deux raisons parce que
pour nous c'est intéressant de
l'attraper alors
ce qui va lui tomber dessus et puis
aussi pour éviter qu'il est représenté
convoquer quelques jours plus tard le
beau-père du jeune homme avoué fait
aujourd'hui mis en examen pour viol et
empoisonnement
d'une manière générale en entrant dans
la police on perd beaucoup d'illusions
sur sur la nature humaine sur sur plein
de choses en fait sur le sur ce que peut
faire l'homme une manière générale et
tout particulièrement à la brigade des
mineurs c'est vrai que on idéalise
sûrement
les rapports entre un père et un enfant
entre une mère et un enfant ce que ce
que peut infliger un parent à son enfant
on est parfois et souvent surpris
jusqu'où ça peut aller on se dit
toujours on verra papi et trois mois six
mois un an après on s'aperçoit qu'on a
encore découvert une affaire encore plus
terrible encore plus odieuse que la
précédente quoi pour faire ce genre de
métier où ce genre protravers il faut
prendre quand même beaucoup de recul
sinon je vais dire on peut pas faire ça
des années sinon
ça prendrait vraiment trop la tête quoi
on voit quand même sordide on touche
quand même le fond
si tu as un investissement je veux dire
une nerveusement intellectuellement
psychiquement oui certainement oui
c'est vrai c'est des très longs
auditions des fois ça peut durer des
heures je veux dire
c'est pas c'est pas forcément une
conversation abaton rompue il faut vous
savez c'est il faut être toute une
technicité il faut poser les bonnes
questions bon moment ça savoir exploiter
des des
silences observer les gens c'est très
important
[Musique]
votre audition est filmée monsieur
d'accord
bon alors ça s'est passé il y a pas si
longtemps que ça
c'est ça monsieur il s'est passé quelque
chose
il s'est passé quelque chose
on est la mère elle devait partir en
vacances alors
pour pas que la petite elle pleure on
est parti faire un tour au parc de au
petit parc de jeux
je peux vous le jurer que je n'ai rien
mis du tout
d'accord moi je peux sur mes parents qui
sont décédés
est-ce que vous êtes en train de nous
dire c'est que si elle dit ça c'est que
peut-être on lui a dit de dire ça voilà
bon alors qui déjà lui aurait dit de
dire ça sert qu'est-ce qu'elle cherche
en faisant
[Musique]
pour accuser quelqu'un de fait comme
cela il faut vraiment lui en vouloir
quoi et puis en plus de tout ça il faut
appliquer une gamine de 4 ans et lui
faire dire des mensonges vous savez
mentir moi aussi ouais bien sûr d'accord
ouais une gamine de 4 ans elle est
peut-être pas aussi forte que qu'un
adulte vous comprenez ça bon elle peut
simplement que de deux choses bien
précises qui sont passées une fois ce
sont passés deux fois la journée du
mercredi monsieur justement quand vous
êtes allé au parc avec elle quand même
c'est quand même bizarre
[Musique]
voilà bon on va vous redescendre
monsieur vous allez
prendre votre poids d'accord
[Musique]
vas-y après 2h d'audition le garder à
vue continue à nier les faits
c'est pas facile non mais on sent qu'il
y a quelque chose à dire mais qui a du
mal à l'évoquer
on va revoir après midi et
éventuellement on ira peut-être en
confrontation avec une gamine 4 avec la
gamine mais enfin 4 ans ça fait
peut-être un peu jeune pour la
confronter on va on va voir on va voir
il faut le réentendre je suis sûr qu'il
y a quelque chose à dire ce monsieur ça
sent c'est pas si simple de dire non
j'ai rien fait c'est un complot
il y a certainement d'autres choses
vraisemblablement voilà
une heure plus tard reprise de
l'audition
[Musique]
alors donc le mercredi après-midi vous
allez au parc de jeux et là qu'est-ce
qui se passe là dans très vite le garder
a vu craque
et puis que vous avez mis votre main
dans sa culotte ça s'est passé comme ça
bon à votre idée c'est des choses qui se
font
comment vous pouvez expliquer ça
j'ai une idée comme ça
est-ce que ça vous a excité
non
qu'est-ce que vous a pris dans la tête
c'était le fait de pouvoir toucher le
sexe de cette petite fille qui
[Musique]
aurait mieux aimé être avec une des
belles filles
que la petite comme leur mère
[Musique]
dans les 30 ans
c'est ça le grand drame c'est pour ça
qu'il y a tous les enfants se font avoir
parce que tout est dans une relation
dans un chat dans une mise en confiance
dans une notion d'autorité d'enfants
adultes etc vous voyez il m'arrivait de
rencontrer des gens qui avaient commis
des choses feraient vraiment pas très
très bien et
qui finissait parier écouter je suis
content de vous l'avoir dit ça me libère
d'un poids
je suis content je suis libéré de vous
l'avoir dit je reconnais mes fautes mais
j'ai libéré ma conscience quelque part
et le différé dans un tribunal c'est
aussi une protection non seulement des
victimes et de lui également ça va
l'amener peut-être à ce à se guérir il y
a la rétention et puis une guérison qui
seront envisagées
trop ce que tu préfères ce qu'elle va
décider ça j'en sais rien j'ai pas envie
de voir
retour au centre éducatif de Liévin
frédéric est attendu dans deux heures
par son juge dernier brief avec Hervé
son éducateur référent c'est toi qui
doit donner à la juge les possibilités
de te faire entrer dans les cursus de
formation moi je vois pas d'autres
sorties par contre effectivement ça peut
aller de à nouveau placement avec des
conditions de formation très
particulière ça fait partie de nos
propositions ça peut aller être l'air
carcération mais ça c'est elle qui
décide
qu'elle va te demander
sur les faits donc là dessus faut pas
que tu t'écoules on a suffisamment
travaillé sur l'idée de responsabilité
pour dire que tu fasses ce qu'il faut
quoi
avec des handisport
c'est comme si que c'était un frère qui
partait quoi parce que j'ai quand même
passé 8 mois avec lui
en même temps en plus
[Musique]
ça y est aujourd'hui le foyer c'est fini
je repars chez moi
je suis trop contente ça va mais après
là moi je dis je vais tout faire pour
avoir des bons trucs les convaincre que
seul ou même accompagné avec ma mère en
dehors je peux faire des bons trucs à
l'époque on est en place
au tribunal pour enfants le jugement est
rendu une condamnation à 12 mois de
prison avec sursis trois ans de mise à
l'épreuve et un contrôle judiciaire
strict là la moindre chose fait que
l'ascension va tomber et là il y a pas
de révocation de quoi que ce soit si les
12 mois tombent les 12 mois tombent donc
ça veut dire le moindre juin ça veut
dire la moindre interclation ça veut
dire le moindre la moindre connerie pour
parler vulgairement les 12 mois tombent
reste dans ces bonnes dispositions là
arrêtez vos conneries je vais essayer
je reviens plus
salut
au revoir tout le
[Musique]
s
très partagé dans le sens où
là il a une décision qu'il satisfait
d'un côté de revenir dans la famille
donc c'est quelque chose qui peut être
stabilisant même si à mon avis ce sera
extrêmement compliqué vu ce qu'on en
connaît de l'environnement social et
familial actuel
après ils sortent dans de bonnes
dispositions
voir si ça continue
on verra la vie dire
[Musique]